-Welcome, welcome,
welcome to the show.
And I love that -- that pop.
-Oh, the pop.
Oh, baby, I can teach you
the pop.
Here. Look at this.
That's for you, Jimmy.
-Really?
-Yes. You know, I'm Shangela.
I come with gifts, baby.
Alright. Now, look.
If you want to do this --
I taught this to
the Vice President, as well,
Kamala Harris,
the Vice President.
-Yes.
-Yes, indeed.
So, it goes like this --
whaaa! -- just like that.
Hold with the thumb,
release with the fore.
You ready?
-Okay.
Hold with the thumb,
release with the fore.
-I believe in you.
[ Drum roll ]
-I've never popped...
-[ Laughs ]
-...I mean, a fan.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-I've never done this.
-Yes, yes.
Ha!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was alright.
-That was lovely.
That was lovely.
-No.
But you know what?
-You know, that was lovely,
but I'm Shangela.
-[ Laughs ]
-I'm a coach. I'm a mentor.
I'm a professional.
-That's right.
-And I strive
for the best with you.
-That was not the best.
-But you can get there.
-Okay.
-So, here we go.
I want you to give it fever,
fire, and ferocious fierceness.
Are you ready?
-Yes.
-Grab -- there you go.
And release the fore.
I want you to give it
some gusto, Jimmy.
Oh, oh, Jimmy.
Okay, here we go.
-[ Chuckling ] Oh, okay.
-Look, baby. Hold.
-Oh, yeah, hold, yeah.
-And release with the fore.
-And release.
-You got it. Ready?
-Yeah.
-One, two, three.
[ Drum roll ]
-Ha!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on. Yes!
-Let me try.
Let me try.
Ready? Drum roll. Here we go.
-Here we go. And...
[ Drum roll ]
One, two, three.
Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes, indeed, better.
-That's what I'm saying.
-That was better.
-I love you, by the way.
I'm just happy.
I just want to clarify something
before we continue the
interview -- cover one thing.
-Yes, I'm a man and all this.
I know.
That's what you were gonna say.
-No, no, no, no, I know that.
Not that question.
I want to know -- you -- you --
you're -- you are not a deejay.
-No. Ooh, thank you,
I must clarify that, as well.
Because -- I say D.J.
because my mom --
Hi, Mom. Hi, Grangela.
Hi, fam.
[ Laughter ]
My mom named me D.J.,
Darius Jeremy.
-Yes.
-Okay? People think that
I'm an actual deejay,
but I don't have that talent.
However, you know -- you know,
if they pay me enough,
I'll get behind a keyboard,
a laptop, and push some buttons.
I'll be
the Paris Hilton of drag!
Yes!
-[ Laughs ] Alright.
You can get back there
and press some buttons, yeah.
But you are not a deejay,
so, no,
don't think that you're
gonna do -- deejay some gig.
-No, out of drag,
my name is D.J.
In drag, Shangela.
-Yeah.
-Not a deejay.
[ Audience cheers ]
-Now, a lot of people know you
from "RuPaul's Drag Race."
And -- But you didn't really
last that long the first --
when --
you were on one episode.
-That is true.
-But you did a genius move.
Can you explain to everyone
what -- what you did?
-Well, you know, I am
a working girl, a professional.
-Mm.
-And I've been a part
of the "RuPaul's Drag Race"
family for years.
I've been there
a number of times.
My first time there, Season 2,
I thought I was about to win,
'cause you know I go
in any room thinking,
"Oh, baby,
I'm about to turn the party."
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I was
the first one voted out.
I'd only been doing drag
for five months,
and I remember getting
to the house and thinking,
"I quit my job for this.
What am I going to do?"
But I had to get up out of
that moment and go to work.
And what I did
is I started calling
different clubs
and booking myself.
'Cause we had a time,
like three months,
between the time they announced
you were on the show
to when you actually, like,
appeared on the show.
-Okay.
-So, I started calling clubs
saying, uh [clears throat]
"Uh, hello."
That's my man voice, okay?
-Mm.
-[ Chuckles ]
Sounds like
my Shangela voice, too.
[ Laughter ]
I was like,
"You really need
to book Shangela.
She is fabulous."
And so I would get them under
contract to have my booking.
So when the show came out,
they said,
"Baby,
you're the first one out."
I said, "Baby, don't worry.
I'm a repeat customer
kind of girl."
And I went in
and turned the party.
-Yeah.
So, you booked yourself...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think it's brilliant.
You book yourself before even
people saw you on the show.
And you go, "Trust me. You're
gonna want to know Shangela."
-Oh, yeah.
I was booking myself.
You know,
I went to SMU in Dallas.
I was also writing
my own press releases
at the time.
-Wow.
-I was a one-stop-shop
kind of diva.
-Now look at you.
Look at what you've done.
I mean, you've done things with
Lady Gaga, with Ariana Grande.
I heard that you once performed
as Beyoncé for Beyoncé.
-True story.
And I'm going to tell you --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, yes, baby, the dolls.
The divas.
I love Lady Gaga.
I love Ariana.
And Beyoncé, is, like, my doll,
my Duchess, my idol.
I love her so much.
She was the first number
I ever performed in 2009
when I first started drag.
So, when she was being honored
at the GLAAD Awards in 2019,
they asked me -- they said,
"Shangela, would you like to
perform a number for Beyoncé?"
I said,
"No, I would like to perform
nine numbers for her, please."
-Exactly.
-A medley.
-Exactly!
-Yes! And I did.
And I remember seeing
at the end,
she and Jay-Z both gave me
a standing ovation.
And I was like, "Oh, my God.
I love them so much."
-And did you get to --
did you get to meet them at all
or talk...?
-Meet Beyoncé?
-Yeah.
-Oh, baby.
I wasn't leaving that building
till I did.
-That's right.
-No. [ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-No, she was so kind.
She was like, "Yes,
I would love to meet Shangela."
So they took me to, like,
this room
where she was meeting people.
And I was standing there --
you know,
dressed as Beyoncé
standing there.
And I look up,
and I'm standing next to Jay-Z.
-Yeah.
-And I was like, "Oh, my God,
I'm next to Jay-Z!
I need to say something cool."
'Cause, you know, I want to be
invited to the house to kick it.
You know?
-Yeah.
-I wanted him to know I'm cool.
So, I was like, "So,
you're from New York, right?"
And he goes,
"Yo, Brooklyn, come on, now."
I was like, "Yes, Brooklyn!
That's right!
I'm from Paris, Texas."
Yeah, he didn't laugh
at my joke.
[ Laughter ]
He was really sweet.
And then I went over
to meet Beyoncé.
And she was like -- you know,
she's the Queen Bey, okay?
-Yeah.
-She just glow --
I was like, "Where is
that light coming from?"
But it was just her.
She was glowing.
-Yeah, she's glowing.
-And, honestly, she was so kind.
She was like,
"You were so good."
-Really?
-I was like, "You're so good."
Like, she was amazing.
[ Laughter ]
-Just repeating her words
back to her.
-I literally was erupting
everything she said
back to her.
-Yeah.
-I couldn't think of anything
to say, but I love her.
-Well, you -- you are glowing,
and you glow.
When you see "We're Here" --
I loved it so much.
Not only is it --
are you funny in it,
but it is so cool,
it is so positive,
and it's emotional.
Like, I really -- I needed a fan
when I watch it.
When I watch you...
[ Laughter ]
-You either need a fan,
or you need a Kleenex.
You know,
'cause I always keep a Kleenex
somewhere near my [bleep].
-Yep.
-Just in case, honey.
[ Laughter ]
-No the show "We're Here" --
I love to tell people --
you didn't see that one coming,
did you?
-No, that was a good one.
-You can have that.
-Thank you. Oh, my gosh.
I appreciate it.
-That's a [bleep] tissue
for Jimmy, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-That's what it's called?
I love it.
-Yes.
-I'm putting this --
I'm putting this in a frame.
-Wonderful.
But, you know, our show --
I'm so happy to host this show
with my friends,
Bob the Drag Queen...
-He's great.
-...and Eureka.
The show is educational...
-Yeah.
-...for those who aren't
familiar with the struggles,
and, also, the triumphs
of the queer community.
But, also, the show is
emotional, as you said,
and entertaining.
-Yeah.
-So, baby, it's some of
the best drag on TV.
And you don't have to be a
member of the LGBTQI+ community
to know that this is something
that people deserve to see.
Because we all need to be --
you know,
we need to feel something.
-Yeah.
-And this show makes you feel
something, for sure.
-Yeah, I love it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Shangela in this Monday's
episode of "We're Here."
Take a look at this.
-Before you speak out
for anybody else,
we got to work here.
There is a way to be happy.
Even if it doesn't come
in the dream
to get a call from everybody
in our family saying,
"We love you.
We were wrong.
We apologize.
We're sorry."
That'd be beautiful.
-Mm-hmm.
-But it might not happen.
So, you're going to
have to change
what you think happiness is,
okay?
-Yeah.
-Kais really needs to celebrate
who he has become.
"I'm living
as an out, loud, and proud
Muslim Tunisian gay man."
I want him to be able to say,
"It's okay to be me."
♪♪
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-D.J. Shangela Pierce,
everybody.
"We're Here" airs Mondays
at 9:00 p.m. on HBO.
Can you give me a "halleloo"?
-Oh, baby, you can always
get a "halleloo."
-Yeah, that's right.
-Halleloo.